well it's uh it's it's snowing here I
don't know if you can see I guess you
probably can't see it in the camera it
looks like I'm broadcasting from the
gates of heaven from the glare but no
it's it's snowing my kids are going nuts
over it of course I mean they're going
absolutely insane running around the
house screaming that it's snowing over
and over and over again and reminding me
in case I forgot nothing shows the sad
disparity between childhood and
adulthood quite like quite like snow
because I can remember being a kid and
seeing how my parents were usually
pretty bummed about snow and I remember
thinking just how sad and and pitiful
they were that how could you how could
you it's like the time when my dad told
me I never forget this my dad told me
once I don't know how it came up but he
said that if he had a choice between
going to Disney World or taking a nap he
would rather take a nap
and I was so scandalized by that as a
child for so long I could not get
because I just thought is that really
what it's like to be a grown-up I didn't
go to you'd rather take a nap than go to
Disney World but now I'm I'm a grown-up
and yeah I would definitely take a nap
over going to Disney World and it's kind
of the same thing with snow even though
I always thought because because Here I
am as an adult and I do I like the look
of snow at least when it's falling but
it's not worth the shoveling in the icy
roads and so on and so on but my kids
right now and this is what I wish that
they would understand what I try to tell
them that they're at the perfect age
right now for Peugeot to pretty much
everything because they're old enough to
enjoy things to go out and have fun but
they're not old enough to have any real
responsibility yet so that is a very
small window of time that's that's a
window of time it's like I don't know
three four five years or something we've
got this window of time where you can
really enjoy your surroundings and you
can enjoy you know activities but you
don't really have any responsibilities
and that's it that's that right there
that that window of time that's when you
basically are gonna have all your fun in
life is right there so just just squeeze
it all in because it's just it's
downhill from there and I think that's
probably why kids why kids at a certain
age all the they never walk they run
everywhere because they're they really
are just trying to fit in all they hate
sleeping they hate sitting down they
hate sitting down for meals because they
just want to get all the fun I guess
they realize at some level that that
this is that right now is the time to
have fun and then pretty soon they're
gonna have sidewalks to shovel and bills
to pay okay um I'm gonna do things a
little bit differently they have several
stories I wanted to talk about so I'm
gonna go through each and talk about
each of them briefly first this thing
with Michael avenatti Michael avenatti
has been arrested on felony domestic
violence charges now there's there's
been a lot of a lot of spiking of the
football by conservatives over this over
this news and you know that's that's
that's understandable at a certain level
because a vanadis of course a low life
but we should remember that apparently a
woman was hurt here she was according to
the charges she was abused and so it's a
sad story because of that so it's not
something we should react gleefully to
because of the fact that somebody was
was hurt apparently but as far as
avenatti himself is concerned look
here's the thing I'm a believer in the
presumption of innocence that is a
bedrock principle of our justice system
it is a it is a bedrock principle of
justice itself justice in general you
have to have the presumption of
innocence but at the same time I know
that avenatti is is not personally a fan
of the presumption of innocence so I
feel like it's only fair to abide by his
preferences and assume that he's guilty
as hell okay because that's that's what
he wants that's what he would want
right he's made it very clear he made it
clear when he was representing Julie
sweat Nick that he really really doesn't
believe in presuming innocence he's not
a fan of that he's also made it clear
that we should believe all women so
again out of respect to him I mean out
of deference to his wishes I feel like
we should assume he's gay
it's only fair it's the respectful thing
okay to do to to to look at this
according to his own preferences so
that's what I'm going to do here for his
own sake I will assume that he's guilty
another story from yesterday the city of
Detroit is apparently moving forward or
moving toward taking Ben Carson's name
off of the off of the the Benjamin
Carson high school of science and
medicine in Detroit now why are they
gonna take it off well because of course
he's a Republican he's a conservative
and he works for the Trump
administration so that's why they're
gonna take the name off why was his name
ever on the school to begin with well
that's because he's a Detroit native and
he also happens to be one of the most
accomplished surgeons in American
history so that seems like a really good
good reason to have his name on on a
school of science and medicine the fact
that he's one of the most accomplished
one of the greatest medical
professionals in the history of the
country so you've got his name on the
School of Medicine that makes a lot of
sense how many how many success stories
like Carson does Detroit really have to
its name in recent decades it would seem
like they don't really have the the
luxury to be picky choosy right I mean
you had you had one of the greatest
medical professionals in history
graduate from your school system in
Detroit you should be trumpeting that
fact everywhere you should name the
whole city after him just to simply
survive the Detroit school system is
impressive enough but to do but to
survive it and then go on and do what he
did well you're not gonna find very many
who can match up to what he accomplished
yet his name is coming off the building
so there are two things to notice here
first of all once again we see how and
this is this is the way it works now in
society we see how a person's entire
identity their worth as a person is
judged by their political and
ideological leanings ben Carson had a
Heol career a historic storied career in
medicine before he dipped his toes into
politics that you know nobody can ever
take that away from him that will always
be there but now we say well unless you
agree with me on politics unless we have
the same ideological opinions then
everything else you've done in your life
is meaningless that's that's essentially
the the strategy now and I think it's I
think it's horrible and the second thing
of course we see is this is this effort
to rewrite history which which now is
reaching absurd Heights I mean it was
bad enough when they were going and they
were you know they were going back to
the tearing down the civil war monuments
and peat taking people's names off of
buildings who were alive back in that
era but now I mean ben Carson is still
alive and we've got to rewrite history
and in Detroit they're going to pretend
this is this should be one of their this
is the this is one of their greatest
sons of Detroit and they're gonna
pretend now that he doesn't exist I
think it's a I think it's just a
horrible trend but there's there's no
end in sight to it okay here's a
cautionary tale that I think we need to
talk about reading now from The Daily
wire it says the couple who raised
nearly half a million dollars for a
homeless man after he gave his last 20
to the woman will face criminal charges
as will the homeless man for making up
the entire story you you probably
remember this this story mark damico
kate McClure and Johnny Bobbitt will
face charges including conspiracy and
theft by deception because they
apparently conspired or allegedly
conspired with one other to make up a
false story in order to raise more than
$400,000 D'Amico and McClure turned
themselves in to Burlington County
authorities on Wednesday after
prosecutors said the day along with
Bobbitt intentionally prevented those
who donated to the GoFundMe page from
accessing relevant information that
would affect their judgment about
solicited contribution to the
fundraising effort the three gained
national attention last year after the
couple claimed that Bobbitt gave his
last one
dollars to help McClure purchase fuel
after she ran out ran out of ran out of
fuel while driving on Interstate 95 in
Philadelphia and then the story goes on
from there if you've been following this
you know that so they raised all this
money and then almost immediately there
was a dispute between the homeless man
and and and the couple because he was
claiming they didn't give him all the
money that was earmarked to them and
next thing you know this couple they're
buying a B and W they're going on these
fancy vacations and it's just I mean
this isn't really the point here but the
the absolute stupidity of of the people
involved in this scheme I mean you so
you come up with this with that you
conspire to make up this story and then
you start suing each other and
backstabbing each other like it wasn't
gonna all fall apart not only that but I
mean you if you really you know you
could have jet there's no reason to even
make up the story you could have covered
your tracks just if the if the woman if
if if the if the homeless guy had
actually just given $20 to the woman
then they could claim that the story
wasn't really made up in other words
they maybe there was some conspiring but
if she had actually just had the guy
physically give her $20 then legally
maybe she could say hey look I'm clear
he did give me $20 but apparently they
didn't even do that much and then they
immediately started stabbing it no honor
amongst thieves I guess is the is the
lesson we learned but there are other
lessons as well and the obvious lesson
is that we shouldn't give our money to a
GoFundMe campaign just because a viral
story tugged our heartstrings and I
think we could be a little bit more more
specific than that
first of all I I become very
uncomfortable I have become
uncomfortable with this with this
GoFundMe stuff because people tend to
give
campaigns without stopping to think
whether a whole boatload of cash is
really what the person in question needs
in in this case you know I made this
point even before we knew the whole
thing was a scam or is allegedly a scam
but in this case even if the whole story
was legitimate it wouldn't be a good
idea even then to give four hundred
grand the homeless guy it is almost a
certainty that a homeless man will have
a drug addiction and alcohol addiction
or severe mental health problems or also
very likely all three that's that's why
he's homeless you know there just aren't
very many sober mentally healthy
homeless people I'm not saying there
aren't any some do exist but the vast
majority are gonna have drug problems
and and mental problems which is very
sad of course and that's why we should
help people in that situation and those
people need help and and they should
receive it but hundreds of thousands of
dollars is not the kind of help that
should be given in those situations you
give 400 grand to a heroin addict and
you've basically killed him now I don't
know that this man's a heroin Adi I'm
just I'm just trying to illustrate my
point that whatever his issue is however
he ended up homeless it's probably going
to be it's not going to be solved with a
whole bucket of cash it's those problems
will probably be made worse and there's
a lot of this kind of thing on on
GoFundMe people asking for money even
though it's not at all clear that money
will actually really solve their
problems or you'll have a GoFundMe where
where someone goes viral for doing
something nice and even though they
aren't homeless we all just send them
money anyway even though money has
nothing to do with anything
or someone
there's a tragedy of some kind and we
feel very badly for them for good reason
but then we start giving them money even
though maybe money has nothing to do
with the tragedy and won't help address
the issue whatsoever I just don't think
it's a smart way to go about things I
also think that um you know one of the
problems with go [ __ ] in there there and
I've donated to GoFundMe campaign it's
plenty of times and there are legitimate
uses for them there are good uses for
them I think for instance when someone's
having a you know with with medical
issues when someone needs help of
medical bills that kind of thing I think
that's a good use for GoFundMe because
in that case you know where the money is
going and and it's easy for the person
who's asking for the money to prove that
they did you know that they did give
their money towards this towards towards
the medical bills so I think that can be
a good use for it but I think so often
you have these problems in and and one
of the other problems with GoFundMe is
that it just it makes it way too easy I
guess for people to ask for money
because you can just set up a page on
GoFundMe and you have it on the Internet
separated from you and then you just sit
back and wait for people to donate from
it so you don't have to go through that
actual human interaction of asking
someone face-to-face for money and I'm
not saying that everyone who needs money
should have to go through the
face-to-face things so that they're
humiliated but I do think that there
should be that human it's just it's just
it's too it's too easy and that's why if
you go and go for me you're gonna find
all kinds of people who are not really
poor are not disadvantaged but they're
just asking for monies like can you help
pay for my college tuition can you just
give me some money for groceries even
though I'm not poor because it's like
why not you know you might as well just
put it up there that people give you
money great but I just it's it's just
it's it's that is not it that it's not
an uplifting and kind of human way to go
about soliciting help from people and
then the third thing is yet the third
problem with GoFundMe for me is that I
think we should be looking more
locally for people to help again it
doesn't mean that we should never give
to GoFundMe campaign but there are
people in our local communities who need
help and I think that we should be we
should be looking there first it's the
principle of subsidiarity it's it's if
there's a problem that problem should be
solved it should be addressed by the
most local authority possible before you
go so if there's someone in the
community who needs help
that problem should be the their their
own community should address that that
problem first before you go to the
entire nation and solicit help so I just
think it's something we need to be
careful with when it comes to these
GoFundMe campaigns one other especially
outrageous story a education teacher in
Florida has been punished for refusing
to oversee a biological female middle
school student who while she's getting
undressed in a boys locker room did you
catch that does that does that make
sense so you've got a female student who
now has decided that she wants to be a
boy and so she wants to use the boys
locker room and and two things happen
first of all the boys in the school
hoo-hoo as as whereas the Federalist
reports were caught literally with their
pants down and you know as they were
getting undressed in a locker room and
this girl walks in and they felt they
felt embarrassed and they were they were
concerned about the fact that they've
got this girl observing them getting
undressed and then on top of that you've
got a male gym teacher who is supposed
to be the one who oversees the boys the
boys locker room but now he's saying
well I can't I'm not gonna I can't be in
there as theirs as the girls getting
changed and now he's in trouble for that
he was reprimanded and he was told that
that he would be transferred to a
different school
letter says with a gag order school
administrators forbade teachers from
talking about the change and ordered a
male PE teacher to supervise the
potentially undressed girl in the chasse
Co middle school locker room chesco or
casco middle school not showed up in
Elsa when he refused to knowingly place
himself in position to observe a minor
female in the nude or otherwise in a
state of undress administrators told him
he will be transferred to another school
as disciplined for not doing his job in
the locker room this is well look
there's there's there's not a lot that
can be said about this because it's so
clearly insane and now we see again how
the me2 thing has has come full circle
and now a man now a grown man just think
about this for a second a grown man is
getting in trouble for respecting a
minor girl's privacy and refusing to be
in the room while she gets chained while
she gets changed so again this is a a
grown man who was in trouble for not
being in the room with a with a with a
girl as she gets changed and then on top
of that you've got all these boys who of
course their wishes don't don't matter
the fact that they feel uncomfortable
that they feel embarrassed that makes no
difference whatsoever because this is
the way things work on the left now that
we've got you know you've got competing
claims of rights and and this because
this girl is the the victim she's in a
victim category as a quote-unquote
transgender so her right claim Trump's
everyone and the fact that everyone is
is made to feel extremely uncomfortable
and embarrassed that does not matter
their feelings don't matter all that
matters is is her which goes back again
to you know the point that I'm always
making is that you know when we see all
this gender identity stuff and we see
how it's how it's much more common now
than it used to be and that tells us
that this is obviously not a natural
phenomenon and it's not just mental
illness either it's there there's
there's it's a cultural thing it is a
trend as well and some people see this
trend and they find something appealing
in it and what do they find appealing in
it what they find appealing is that it
is so self-serving it is so egotistical
and arrogant where you get to say that
only my feelings and opinions matter and
everyone else just has to deal with it
because I'm gonna do what's comfortable
for me and if it's not comfortable for
you it doesn't matter and that mentality
is being encouraged we are we are
fostering that mentality in kids and
encouraging it when you know this girl's
parents I don't know who what her
parents are doing or who they are but
however they feel about the transgender
thing is the but what they should be
saying to their daughter is you know
what I know it maybe it would make you
feel more comfortable to be changing
with the boys but it does it makes them
uncomfortable and it makes your teacher
uncomfortable and so there are a lot of
people who feel reasonably uncomfortable
and feel like their private space is
being invaded so you should respect that
you should have respect for other people
the left tells us so much or we have to
you know these if someone is gender
identity issues with our transient we
have to respect them okay well can we
tell them to respect us what does the
respect ever go the other way why is the
respect only ever going one way
shouldn't they also be told to respect
other people where is their respect for
other people finally just one dimension
but I can't wrap this up without
mentioning this because it's very
important a new study published this
week proved scientifically that bearded
men are more attractive than non bearded
over 8,000 women were surveyed and most
rated bearded men as most attractive and
clean-shaven men as least now this of
course comes as comes as no surprise to
me though I do feel bad for my baby
faced
brothers macaws it's hard enough for
them to walk around every day with the
faces of preschoolers but then to be
told that they are repellent to women as
well that's just I mean that's just a
that's a tough break so I'm I'm sorry
guys I really am but you know maybe you
should think about having the face of a
man because that's obviously what what
women want all right we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed